We just learned how to take two
data sets with the same fields and
union them together to
make a longer data set.
But what if you want to blend multiple
data sets with different data?
For instance,
pretend we want to create this really
great 360 view of our customers, so
we can build a predictive model from it.
We'll want to start with as much
information about the customers
that we can get,
before we can determine which variables
we'll want to use in the model.
We'll take a transaction data set that's
summarized to the customer level,
showing their total transactions,
total spend, etc.
Then we might want to use
another data set that shows what
marketing campaigns they responded to.
Maybe, we can even pull in a third data
set with their address data showing
how far these customers are located
from their store locations.
To blend these data sets together,
we'll need some information in common
amongst all three of these files.
That information in common
is what's going to tie
each record in each data set to
the same record in the other data sets.
In the example here,
we can see that each data set has an ID
number associated with each record.
We use this field to join
the three data sets together.
However, we may not always have a field
like ID to join data sets together with.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You need to look at the fields
in your data sets and
figure out which fields can be
used to join to other data sets.
For instance, maybe you're joining data
sets together related to products.
In that case, you might be able to
use some kind of product code or SKU.
Which stands for stock keeping unit.
And is frequently represented
by a machine bar code.
Or maybe you have to use a combination
of fields that might make the record
unique.
For instance, if you don't have
a customer ID on each record,
maybe you have to join on first name,
last name,
and address fields to identify
the same customers in each data set.